good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-354
object class ketter
special containment procedures due to
scp-354's
immobile nature area 354 has been built
around it
area 354 houses forces and d-class
personnel
prepared to deal with the threats
emerging from scp-354
as well as researchers studying scp-354
and its properties for their own safety
no on-site personnel are to approach
scp-354
at any time direct interaction with
scp-354
is permitted only for the purpose of
research to eliminate
scp-354 and must be approved
by o5 personnel area 354 was constructed
to contain
and neutralize any and all further
threats emerging from scp-354
at the heart of area 354 a 20-foot wall
of concrete reinforced with
has been constructed around scp-354 to
prevent emerging entities from escaping
into the area at large
high-speed motion detection cameras are
placed atop the wall
looking down into the pool and armed
guards can easily shoot down into the
enclosure
from catwalks placed above the pool
description scp-354 is a pool of red
liquid
discovered in northern canada the liquid
is a consistency similar to that of
human blood
hence the colloquial name blood pond but
it is not of a biological nature
the pool does not have definitive banks
soil mixes with the liquid until
at a certain point there is more soil
than liquid and the ground is mostly
solid
the liquid becomes denser as one
descends deeper into the pool
if the pool has a bottom it has yet to
be reached
periodically entities emerge from the
pool and attempt to escape from the
enclosure
thus far nearly all creatures emerging
from scp-354 have been extremely hostile
and highly dangerous scp-354 is believed
to have been first discovered
by survivors of a plane crash who
encountered scp-354 by
chance scp-354 had developed into a
local urban legend
long before foundation personnel arrived
to deal with the threat
after locating the source of the legend
scp personnel set up watch station
epsilon 38 to monitor the pool and deter
future travelers from finding it scp-354
was classified as euclid
until its properties were further
discovered
at 1403 hours on an unidentified entity
emerged from scp-354
contact with watch station epsilon 38
was lost
mobile task 4 was dispatched to deal
with the entity and
were eventually successful all personnel
at watch station epsilon 38
were found dead area 354 was
subsequently constructed
to contain scp-354
document 354 1 a partial log of entities
to have emerged from scp-354
prior to event 354-20
scp-354-1 original entity which
destroyed watch station epsilon 38
resembled a giant bat neutralized by
mobile task force
scp-354-2 bear-sized mammalian creature
covered in razor-sharp spines
resembled an echidna was virtually
bulletproof but was unable to escape the
enclosures surrounding the pool
neutralized via napalm scp-354-3
metallic sphere capable of levitation
emitted concentrated levels of radiation
and precisely directed beams
sufficient to instantly [ __ ] and
later result in death
then area head doctor struck scp-354-3
with a sledgehammer
disabling it scp-354-3 then
self-detonated causing minor structural
damage and severely wounding doctor
doctor made a full recovery and has been
commended for his bravery
scp-354-4 humanoid reptilian creature
approximately 4.6 meters tall escaped
both the walled enclosure and area 354
altogether gunfire caused very little
harm
and was highly ineffective mobile task
force omega-7
pandora's box was dispatched and was
successful in neutralizing the creature
scp-354-5
scp-354-6 appeared to be a human male of
indian descent
as the enclosure around the pool had not
yet been fully repaired
scp-354-6 was immediately shot
before it had a chance to escape area
head doctor
has expressed his displeasure in the
rash execution of scp-3546
which testing revealed to be identical
to an average human being
scp-354-14
majority of the creature's body remained
well beneath the surface of the pool
five octopus-like tentacles were seen
emerging from the pool
and reached up over the enclosure
several d-class personnel were grabbed
by the tentacles and pulled back beneath
the surface of the pool
after receiving massive damage from
gunfire scp-354-14
retreated back into the pool and
disappeared
no personnel taken by the creature were
recovered
scp-354-15
feline creature composed of a blue-hued
crystalline structure
later revealed to be ice was able to
jump above the walled enclosure
and was agile enough to dodge most
gunfire
was actively hostile and mauled any
personnel that engaged it
subject engaged scp-3416 upon its
emergence from the pool
and was terminated in the fight
scp-354-16
a feline creature composed of a dark red
black stone
later revealed to be partially
solidified magma
gunfire proved mostly ineffective
against its hide
was not hostile to personnel and did not
attempt to escape the walled enclosure
until being engaged by a cp 354-15
successfully terminated scp-35415
and grew less active as its body cooled
after fully solidifying and having
remained motionless since
the subject was moved to dr office for
aesthetic purposes
scp-354-18
metallic humanoid machine described by
several d-class personnel
as a terminator subject possessed a
cloaking device rendering it invisible
to human eyes
subject was highly adept at combat and
killed nearly 90 percent
of area 354's guard personnel as it
rampaged through the facility
approximately 60 minutes after emerging
from the pool
subject ceased function and powered down
subject was dismantled and power cell
was disposed of
subjects remains are under study note
from area head
that's thrice now that we've had to fall
back on pandora's box
to deal with stuff coming out of scp-354
able can't complain though you can tell
he enjoyed fighting scp-354-11
maybe we should set up some kind of
hotline to mobile task force omega 7
document 354 3 a
log of exploratory mission 354
alpha personal log of dr
our expedition to explore scp-354
that gaping wound in the middle of
canada has finally been accepted
the r d boys have come up with what can
only be described as a submarine with a
drill on it
we know that the pool gets denser as you
go down so
we suspect that at some point we won't
be sinking so much as digging
hence the huge mining device built onto
it it's not hydrodynamic at all
but we're not really going swimming here
my gut tells me that there's something
on the other side of the red pool and
just like digging down
up to china all we have to do is dig
down
up to it personal log of doctor
had a nice long debate with ol5 over
who's allowed to come
i wanted mobile task force omega 7 to
come with us for protection
or at least scp-076 but they won't allow
it
despite the massive damages he continues
to cause they still
see him as too valuable to risk losing
not that he isn't you know
immortal or anything maybe they just
don't have the guts to ask him to go
exploring
ackler that ass wanted us to take scp
with us but i wouldn't allow it the file
says scp
was just born here before he came
through so he'd be useless as a guide
he might have been some use of security
but that's mostly canceled out by the
fact that he
he probably just anyway
the final crew compliment apart from
myself consists of
three agents two d-class personnel one
geologist
and one guy from r d who's going to
pilot the ship
i already forgot all their names
exploratory team 354 alpha et 35a
mission log day one
rotten sort of day to begin a mission
rumor has it that last night there was
a total containment breach in some area
or other
then it turns out that there's no coffee
allowed anywhere inside of area 354
for some reason or another and the whole
mission almost ended in a disaster when
it turns out that they almost forgot to
load the extra fuel on board
who the [ __ ] is running the show around
here
anyway we're now underway for a while
there i had a definite feeling
of going downward but now we're dropping
much more slowly
marty the r d guy's name says we're
sinking at a rate of 10 meters an hour
apparently at this depth the red pool is
pretty damn dense
et354a mission log day two
nothing of interest happened but i
learned everyone's names
we have marty our pilot agent swanson
agent turquoise agent 86 dr j
mcarthur chris simmons and leroy tucker
whoop do you [ __ ] do et354a
mission log day three at about four a.m
gravity suddenly changed direction boy
that was a fun way to wake up
now we're rising rather than sinking
which means
we're more than halfway there et354a
mission log day four we've reached the
surface
through the portholes it's mostly dark
which means it's night
we can't go out yet because for all we
know the atmosphere could be
hydrochloric acid
and we've got a shitload of sensors
outside the ship analyzing a bunch of
stuff
whether the air is breathable what kind
of airborne bacteria we have to deal
with
and simple stuff like temperature we'll
know in eight hours if it's safe for
human life out there
et 354a mission log day five
turns out the air is totally safe except
it's been night for
going on 28 hours now what's going
on et354a
mission log day6 dawn finally came
the sun was huge and red i'm a biologist
but i know enough about astronomy to
know that we're orbiting a totally
different star
is this a different time a different
place
or a different dimension leroy guessed
that we're in
another plane of existence and i think
he's probably closest
the pool on this side is way bigger more
like a large
pond or maybe a small lake the banks are
more defined than our side as well
we took an inflatable raft to shore
martian simmons stayed behind
and headed north the ground here or at
least
around the pool is almost totally devoid
of plant life
the only green we saw was a sort of
fuzzy moss
growing on the ground that looked like a
kind of mold
the ground is grayish tan dirt that's
like a mixture of sand and flower
macarthur said it was some sort of
mineral or another but i forget what he
called it
i half expected our electronics to not
work out here but
that wasn't the first thing to fail
after about two hours of hiking across
flat boring ground the compass suddenly
changed direction
now it points to what we had previously
thought to be east
evidently this planet's magnetics is it
even a planet
they'll work the same way ours do not
wanting to get lost we immediately made
a 180 and headed back to the ship
i could have sworn the trip back was
less than half as long as the trip out
tomorrow we'll work out a way of
navigation that doesn't rely on the
compass being seen
et354a mission log day seven
lousy night sleep the sun never went
down
by my calculations the day night cycle
here seems to last about 43 and a half
hours
as opposed to 24 hours back home that's
gonna take
some getting used to we agreed on a
system of navigation
firstly we're going to travel only in a
straight line to make sure that we can
get back to the ship by
simply turning around and heading in the
other direction
unless we encounter some kind of
unnavigable jungle we should be fine
secondly marty's rigged a radio beacon
thing i don't really remember his
explanation but if we're anywhere within
800 miles his little gizmo will be able
to tell us exactly which direction to go
to
to get back and how far
et354a mission log day nine
we set out a few hours before the sun
was scheduled to rise
but when we got to the shore we found
that the green moss stuff was
everywhere it had grown in mass
significantly
my guess is this stuff shrivels up in
the sun during the day
and expands at night to suck in
nutrients or something
we decided we didn't want to walk
through it so we went back and waited
for sunrise
sun came up and we set out again the
moss stuff was back to its smaller state
it just occurred to me that there's been
no wind at all in this place
the result is dead silence i'm not
ashamed to admit that the overall
emptiness of this place is
pretty scary we found an area with none
of the moss stuff for a few hundred feet
around
and decided to camp for the night the
sun is still up but
it's time for us humans to sleep so i'm
calling it a night
et354a mission log day 10.
sometime in the night which was really
daytime [ __ ] this is gonna get confusing
we were all awoken by some kind of roar
you remember what the t-rex sounded in
that old movie jurassic park
it sounded a lot like that big reptilian
it was so loud that i was certain
whatever was making it couldn't be more
than 20 feet away
but when we all got out of our tents we
didn't see anything
the whole area is so flat that we'd see
any sort of animal within half a mile or
so
but there was nothing [ __ ] scary
we packed up camp and continued on after
a while we stopped seeing the moss stuff
maybe it only grows around the red pool
and the ground became
rockier in the distance the land seems
to grow more hilly
i think i see trees eg 354a
mission log day 11. the bare ground has
ended
now we're walking across a vast field of
beautiful green grass
it almost looks like a well-known lawn
the grass seemed ordinary enough until
turquoise tripped over a rock and arose
to find his hands covered with several
dozen bloody pinpricks
apparently the tip of a blade of this
grass is incredibly sharp
and easily punctures skin it's no threat
to our foundation-issued boots
but we must be careful not to fall on it
we came to a tiny stream really no more
than a trickle
swanson suggested we could refill our
canteens but
leroy and macarthur wanted to check the
water for something or other first
macarthur took out some equipment and
after a few minutes
announced that it was not water but
liquid carbon dioxide
co2 is usually a gas at this temperature
and it's never a liquid
the laws of physics don't seem to be
working right
et34a mission log day 14.
i haven't had time to record anything
for a few days we made it to an area
sparsely populated by trees
the grass there was withered and brown
but not sharp enough to pierce the skin
anymore
the trees were ordinary looked like
birch but the leaves were wrong
at some point we lost swanson this place
is so quiet that none of us
really feel comfortable talking so we
have no idea when we lost him
there's a good eight-hour window where
he could have gone missing
we called to him but none of us wanted
to split up to look for him
during the night a tree fell on 86's
tent
he wasn't hurt and none of the gear was
damaged although the tent got mangled
beyond repair
86 swears that the tree hadn't been that
close when he pitched the thing
and none of us can tell what caused it
to fall the trunk just
snapped we all agreed not to pitch our
tents anywhere near a tree from now on
the next day which was really night we
are the same roar from a few days ago it
sounded exactly the same as before
and again we have no idea what made the
sound
and none of us can even agree which
direction it came from
then it started to rain we all pitched
our tents for the night
this time a whole lot closer together
than we had before
the nearest tree is about 300 feet away
macarthur commented that it was actual
rain
and not more co2 [ __ ] and we set up
this funnel thing to refill our canteens
leroy donated his tent to agent 86 and i
offered to share mine since it's a
little bigger than the other guys
i asked leroy what he did to wind up as
a d-class
he said he a couple of people i think he
might have been trying to freak me out
but who knows anyway he's one of the
most well-behaved d-classes i've ever
met
so i don't think he's going to say
in my sleep et 354-a
mission log day 17. good god
the rain has finally stopped everything
is soaking wet
including us except for the ground
after that much water you'd expect it to
be muddy as hell but the ground beneath
the grass is barely damp at all perhaps
the plants absorb moisture from the
ground more efficiently than the ones
back home
we're setting out again perhaps the rain
awakens some
animal life mission log
day 25 what seemed to be a huge cliff in
the distance turned out to be an
artificially constructed wall
it's made of solid rusty iron and stands
maybe 50 feet high
to the left and to the right it goes on
farther than the eye can see
i can't imagine how thick it is we have
no way around it
we'll have to go over it or through it
we made a camp for the night
we'll work out what to do in the morning
et354a
mission log day 26 leroy jury rigged
some kind of blowtorch thing with our
equipment
i swear this guy is [ __ ] macgyver
we cut a hole in the iron wall big
enough for us to go through
turns out it's only about a quarter of
an inch thick but there's another wall
behind it with less than a foot between
apparently this thing has multiple
layers leroy cut through eight of them
before we finally made it to the other
side
the grass on this side is black not
burnt or anything just
a different color and finally there's
some wind
i was getting tired of concluded that
coming here was a mistake
we have to turn back et354a
mission log day 39 we passed through the
second barrier
and we're back to the weird place with
the black grass i have expected the
whole leroy cut through it to have
sealed up or something
but it was still there thank god for
whoever runs the show in this world
i don't think macarthur is going to make
it through the night he's lost a lot of
blood
et 354a mission log day 40.
we awoke to find that macarthur had
crossed we didn't want to do it but we
had no choice but to terminate him
86 said that something back home might
be able to help him
and he may have been right but we
couldn't afford to have him slow us down
we only have a few more days in a48
we made it back to the ship with only an
hour or two to spare
the first thing they asked us was what
the [ __ ] had happened to swanson
turquoise macarthur and 86 as if a few
dead team members are our biggest
problems right now
marty has us underway and we're
definitely sinking
i just hope they don't end the vlog
this document was discovered at the
central foundation database
no such mission to explore scp-354 has
been yet suggested
or approved no records of any personnel
mentioned in this log
exist the log's origin is unknown
note from area head doctor
it has been 22 months since the last
entity emerged from the pool
before this the longest period of time
between emergencies
was eight months i suspect this means
one of two things
either the red pool has died or powered
down or whatever the correct
term for it is or it is charging up
for something big to come through 05
believes the former has the most likely
explanation
and has recalled 30 percent of our total
personnel and cut
25 percent of our funding while i can
only hope that they are correct
if the latter situation is true we are
soon to face
some terrible monstrosity and we won't
have anywhere near the force necessary
to deal with it
i worry for all of our safety
document 354 4 event log
354.20 in the morning if
the entire staff of area 354 evacuated
the facility
however the staff also shut down the
power to the area and took a number of
supplies and vehicles from the facility
indicating that the evacuation had not
been done due to an emergency
mobile task force theta 12 was
dispatched to investigate the cause of
the evacuation
and if possible make contact with area
staff however before mobile task force
theta-12 could make contact with area
354
or its evacuees the area's on-site
warhead was detonated
resulting in the destruction of the
entire facility and the death
mobile task force theta 12 was ordered
to make contact with the evacuated
personnel
and in the event of hostility was given
clearance to terminate
any uncooperative personnel a large
convoy of vehicles taken from area 354
was spotted heading southward from area
354
at high speed final audio logs from
mobile task force theta 12
indicate that the convoy was made up of
area 354
staff and that the previous chain of
command had broken down
in its entirety with armed d-class
personnel and research personnel
firing upon mobile task force theta 12.
mobile task force theta 12 was
annihilated and no further contact with
the former personnel of area 354 has
been made since
document 354 5
following the total destruction of area
354
the red pool containment site was
constructed in its place
basic maps of the new facility can be
found
unlike the previous facility which was
focused on research and neutralization
of entities emerging from scp-354
the new facility is devoted entirely to
the containment
of scp-354 and entities which may emerge
from it
as well as any unforeseen forces which
it may create directly
this is due largely to the advisement of
the new sighthead
who believes that the events of log
354-20 were the result of a psychic or
mental attack
generated by scp-354 itself
document 354 6.
interview regarding playing log
now is it all right if i record this
yes go ahead good good
so let's start at the beginning
what happened at the red pool
containment site looking back now it
seems
strange that nobody ever suggested
draining the pool when doctor
came up with it it seemed like such a
good idea at the time
what exactly about the idea was so
appealing
it was a way out that scp entry
i've read what it says it's a joke
it makes it seem like we have the pool
under control
i take it you do not there's a half
meter slab of reinforced concrete in
place over the pool
and yet every time some beast tries to
come through
somehow it manages to get loose into the
building
people die every single time
i've seen man's own intestines
can you imagine what that looks like oh
man
so to you and of course to the other
people stationed at the red pool
containment site as well
draining the pool seemed like a fine
solution to the suffering caused by
scp-354
suffering that thing doesn't just please
sit
down this is going on record
so o5 approved the draining of scp-354
and then what happened they evacuated
all the non-essential personnel to a
location couple kilometers away
leaving just basic defense crew and the
people who'd run the equipment mostly
d-class
plus a few agents to keep things going
and you were among
those agents yes
how did they go about draining the pool
tech guys brought in this big
pump thing with all these hoses we
retracted the slab
but but
have you ever had a dream where it
seemed so
real but you knew you were dreaming and
i felt like you had to wake up to escape
from it
i can't say i have yes you have
we all have that's what it felt like
when they put the hose in to try and
drain it
everything stopped being real it was
like
we had to escape right now and you were
the only one
feeling this sensation no everyone
had it at the same time it came from the
[ __ ] pool
please lower your voice
what happened when they activated the
pump we never did
we couldn't it wouldn't let us
what wouldn't let you the poor please i
ask you to lower your voice
up until now it's been content just
throwing monsters out
it's been playing but now we have it
locked up
and we just tried to execute it now it's
angry
god's restraint my buddy measured its
banks once and compared them to the
photos from its first discovery
you know what he found god it's growing
the pool is growing
it gets bigger and stronger every day
and now
we've made it angry sedate him we'll
continue this in the morning
if he's lucid by that anyway
end log
okay i think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are
and you are all dismissed goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
the morrigan james saba
arbiter soul it's not a spoon
darius tan justin day
nj vujak corey barker
longinus the commissar
chloe harlan and samurai corgis
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vulgar
thank you
you